بامكانكم سيدي تبدو الخواتم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مبارك سيدنا وعقبال سيدي هاشم
وستي سلمى ان شاء الله تضلك دائما البهجه
في كل افراحنا ورمز عزتنا وشموخنا وان شاء
الله ربنا يعطيك الصحه والعافيه وطوله
العمر ومن بعد اذنك سيدي بدي ابارك لجلاله
الملكه وللاسره الهاشميه الكريمه
وللاردنيين جميعا عزوه سيدي حسين واهله
وعشيرته
ولاهل العروس اللي هم اهلنا ونسايبنا
وايضا ربنا يحفظ الجميع جميع الحضور اللي
شاركونا فرحتنا اليوم فرحه الاردن واسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى انه يديم عليكم الفرح
والمسره مبارك سيدي مبارك سيدي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات